what you see in here is a tree stump
wrapped in leather Foley artist Marco
Costanzo of c-5 sound thought of this
innovative combination when he had to
make the noises for Manny the mammoth in
Ice Age it helped capture the sound of a
massive creature stomping on the ground
Marco needed to make sure he got an
object that accurately captured not only
this creatures weight but also the
pattern in which a creature of this size
would walk in this case heel to toe
fully artists use objects to create
sounds based on the characters movements
and interactions we have to make sounds
that embellish their their movements
Marcos done Foley sounds for movies like
Goodfellas Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
and The Big Lebowski
but mimicking the sounds of animals
isn't as easy as wolfing or purring
though he can do that too picking the
right sounds involves carefully
examining both objects and surfaces take
horses galloping for instance a pair of
plastic coconut shells could certainly
do the trick but when it came time to
make the horse sounds for a movie like
2010's True Grit remake I used rocks
because you can hear the sound of the
impact when using coconut you might hear
that little cooker cook but when I use a
rock I hear boom boom boom if you ever
hear and ride a horse you're hearing
that 2000 5000 pound animal on every
footstep gold while the plastic shells
might work on cobblestones marco
realized you can barely hear them in
dirt the surface the horses and True
Grit were most likely to tread upon I'm
not going to use because there's no
weight and you don't really even hear
the that cavity sound these would be the
medium sized immediately you can hear a
little bit more of the bottom end right
and my favorite of the rocks
you're getting a low-end thud right
along with your crunchy an animal size
is a big factor especially when that
animal is tiny Marco did the sounds for
the dragonfly in the opening of 1997's
men in black we were really playing with
different kinds of paper and cards I
remember one of the ideas will put a put
a card in a bicycle spoke and spin it
and you hear that and everyone's like
yeah I'm great but you hear the battle
metal spoke well and then the question
was well how do we do that and not get
it sound like metal how do you get it
sound organic like an animal Marco found
the right sound using handheld fans with
the fans marco could more easily adjust
the dragonfly's variation in movement by
putting his finger on the blade a
different challenge arose when working
on Marley & Me which chronicles a dog's
life from puppy to old age Marco had to
figure out how to make the dog sound
different at different ages so it wasn't
just about size but how an animal grows
over time I have two different size
nails on them these are the smaller ones
and you can see there's bigger ones on
that side and they sound distinctively
different listen to this one these are
the small ones now I would flip these
around I'm not gonna flip right now
here's a younger more excited dog and
the same dog at a much older age and for
some scenes Marco had to layer a track
for the dog's collar for a bigger dog
Marco used a heavy chain and a smaller
dog has a smaller collar so you just
hear the tags so every time they're
moving their head you think they're so
cute yeah but non-stop noise it's not
just a one sound fits all type of deal
for gigantic animals like that mammoth
from Ice Age Marco had to create
multiple sounds and then have them
layered to truly
capture the physical scope of the
character when we went to do a second
track picked up a bunch of grass and at
the same time we rolled this then he
added some pebbles and twigs to capture
things the mammoth might be stomping on
there are plenty of other considerations
that go through the mind of a Foley
artist when making animal sounds like
how many animals there are if I was
doing a single bird and it was flying
I'd be like in rhythm fast taking off
[Music]
flock of birds I wouldn't even use
feathers I would probably use gloves for
that when it comes to eating
Marco might need to think about whether
the food is wet or dry or whether the
animal has a snout for example if it's a
horse
chewing celery I put my hands up to here
because you get a little bit of a a
cavity there and it's those cavities
that sell the sound on some occasions if
a digital library won't do he'll also
have to do the vocals himself
[Music]
to see a Foley artists thought process
about animal sounds in action
we put Marco to the test by showing him
a stock video clip with no sound that he
had never seen before definitely got a
few tracks to do cuz you got the claw on
the ground you got the claw on the thing
yet the teeth on the on the mat you got
the body movement the fur for the mat
Marco found one in his studio with very
similar material we do the the paws
first and for paws we just need a pair
of leather gloves for the lion's teeth
he used this small block of wood with
nails drilled into it which he created
for the tiger in Life of Pi work on sink
he brought back the wood blocks for the
Cubs scratching the claws which are very
similar to the teeth they have different
action they were pulling at it here it's
gripping I have the a few different
varieties of fur here we've got the the
astroturf the cat is moving along it so
we're gonna rub his body along the
bottom as he pulls himself forward real
close is a very small sound that'll be
the most convincing sound because all of
a sudden you go from just an animal
that's there moving around to you have
the feeling of it against the floor you
feel its its presence to top it all off
a few collar shakes and a few chews with
this little guy I'm only opening my
mouth and doing a like maybe 50% of the
volume I could get you know right now
he's got a little tongue lick that we're
gonna get up a little bit of a
slobbering sound remember cat also has a
dry tongue it might be a little
sandpapery but and you know what when
it's on itself it's just up then a fully
mixer watched the footage and layered it
all together
so what makes watching this without
sound and then with sound different the
sounds that we make brings you into the
personality of the animal you you become
closer to it and you want to give it a
personality you want to give the sounds
of personality and you can do it by its
sound movements
that's what fully artists do we give
detail
[Music]